for a moment we want you to cast your
mind back to your childhood a time when
you weren't as busy or burdened with the
pressures of life that come as you grow
up when you were carefree and had your
whole life ahead of you nothing but
potential and opportunity a simpler time
when the highest award you could achieve
wasn't a grade or a promotion but
something as simple as your mom or dad
pinning a drawing you did to the door of
the refrigerator oh to be a kid again
right then again maybe returning to
younger days is better left as a fantasy
it's hard to imagine that something so
pure so simple and wholesome as a
drawing on the fridge could ever be
something dark horrific even but then
you learn about scp-683
and all of a sudden returning to your
childhood becomes something you hope
never happens scp-683
is an anomaly with various parts to it
so we'll start with scp-683
at first glance it looks to be just an
ordinary refrigerator to be more precise
it's actually a 1953 crosley shelvador
for any of you fridge experts out there
who are curious about the exact make and
model of scp-683-1
for everyone else picture the
refrigerator that indiana jones hid
inside to miraculously survive a nuclear
blast in kingdom of the crystal skull
that was such a plot device i don't know
about you guys but i'm feeling nervous
already like we said at first glance
you'd struggle to spot anything out of
the ordinary about this particular
fridge apart from maybe some slight wear
and tear on the outside inside though
it's perfectly clean kept in perfect
working condition for keeping food cool
but that's the first weird thing about
scp-683-1
you see despite the foundation
conducting tests to deliberately make it
messier the fridge seems to have an
inbuilt function that you wouldn't find
in one from home depot it can self-clean
yes that doesn't sound all that
impressive unless you're a fridge owner
yourself and know what a nightmare they
can be to keep clean while it's
definitely weird it's not the last of
scp-683-1's anomalous properties the
next is the fact that the power cord of
this refrigerator ends with a plug that
doesn't match any known type of wall
outlet seems even stranger after all who
would design a fridge that can't even be
plugged in right in fact the scp
foundation had to design their very own
completely one-of-a-kind adapter to
connect
scp-683-1 to an ordinary gas-powered
home generator once plugged in though
scp-683-1 functions exactly like you
would expect any other refrigerator to
sort of it's about time we move on to
scp-683 second component designated as
scp-683-2
again much like the fridge it is somehow
a fix to at first look this part looks
completely ordinary it's a drawing
created using felt pens and pencils
presumably by a child between the ages
of 5 and 7 years old there's evidence of
some moderate water damage to the paper
but once again nothing all that strange
to look at even the subject of this
child's drawing is pretty mundane just
some scribbles of a pleasant mountainous
landscape a house a well a dog a figure
wearing a chef's took and of course an
anthropomorphic son with a smiley face
now sure that might not sound all that
impressive but we would advise you not
to say anything like that out loud
criticizing the drawing is a comment you
might wish you hadn't made just like
when you fill our comment sections with
dated among us memes seriously it's
getting old any person that makes any
kind of negative or disparaging remark
about the scp-683-2
drawing or tries to remove the paper
from the fridge door of scp-683-1
will suffer a grim horrific fate the
next time they try to eat anything this
person will suffer immense irreparable
damage to their internal organs along
with their skin and muscle tissue this
is intensely painful causing the subject
agonizing pain as their organs and skin
are melted down the amount the person
loses is equal to the mass of food
they've eaten with each bite they will
lose more and more of their body the
painful process will not stop until they
have ingested 0.42 kilograms of food
making this even worse the process
doesn't seem to target any organs that
would kill the subject immediately
they're made to suffer in excruciating
pain punished with torture for daring to
try and remove the drawing from the
fridge any and all subjects will die
within 26 days of taking that final bite
and thus losing the last piece of
themselves but where do the body parts
of these people go surely they don't
disappear you must be thinking and you
would be right in instances like this
the third mystery component of scp-683
is revealed referred to as scp-683-3
a brown paper lunch bag will manifest
inside the
scp-683-1 fridge containing a grim and
grisly assortment of meals on every
occasion the bag contains a sandwich
with a pretty disgusting filling
the flesh and viscera of the last person
who dared to criticize the drawing on
the refrigerator there is also a plastic
ziploc bag in which you'll find the
other half of the stolen organs and
flesh of this unlucky person along with
three chocolate chip cookies
surprisingly these are actually
completely normal cookies with no traces
of dna or other abnormalities to them
every time there is also one final item
that forms the contents of scp-683-3
and that's a note which reads be a good
boy today this note bears the same
handwriting as appears on the outer
surface of the paper bag upon which a
single name is written eric now for
those of you in the know about the
various anomalies of the scp foundation
that particular unassuming name might
sound very familiar it was the same name
mentioned by another anomaly known as
scp-066
a brief bit of context for you
scp-066 was a living ball of yarn that
displayed friendly behavior towards
foundation staff however during an
experiment a thread was cut from scp-066
body this caused the yarn to transform
into a ball of meat with a pair of
functional eyes protruding from it
scp-066 became hostile constantly asking
for an eric whenever someone gets too
close to it the same name eric was also
found carved into the back of scp-168
another anomaly encountered by the scp
foundation
scp-168 was an anomalous calculator
which actually possessed some level of
sentience and had the ability to
communicate so who is eric well theories
range far and wide but there's no real
definitive answer as to exactly who or
what eric might be some claim he's a
bending entity
others posit he's an scp that the
foundation just doesn't know about yet
regardless he's connected to some
intriguing entities a sentient
calculator a formerly friendly ball of
yarn and a fridge with a child's drawing
on it that can steal people's organs and
put them in a lunch bag especially for
him it would seem that eric is a child
maybe a schoolboy possibly even the one
responsible for the drawing on
scp-683 this child could even
potentially be anomalous in nature of
course this is all just rampant
speculation on our part so it's probably
best to take all of that with a grain of
salt as we've said before it is just a
theory an scp explained theory eric
might just remain one of the
foundation's many unanswered mysteries
for years to come but if that answer
doesn't satisfy you then why don't we go
back to scp-683
maybe something in the fridge's origin
will give us a further clue to the
mystery of who eric is the fridge was
first discovered by the scp foundation
in the storage unit of a washington home
owned by a woman named yolanda as
coincidence would have it yolanda was a
collector of vintage home furnishings
including refrigerators which would
probably explain why she didn't think to
throw out such an old model of fridge
from the 1950s
according to her she found scp-683
simply left on a nearby street corner
with nobody around that could have left
it there or anyone that could have
possibly been transporting it to the
local dump to give her a hand moving the
fridge yolanda enlisted the help of her
nephew who agreed to step in and assist
her in getting scp-683 back to her house
unfortunately though the nephew passed
away only two weeks later apparently due
to medical complications that came as
the result of a hernia according to his
death certificate could yolanda's nephew
have been the mysterious and elusive
eric could something have happened to
him after his death that allowed him to
become some kind of anomaly who's to say
we can only guess and hope that one day
we might get a full answer as to why
yolanda never suffered the effects of
scp-683
she never actually tried to take the
scp-683-2 drawing down from the fridge
when asked why she simply replied it's a
nice little picture isn't it why take it
down maybe just maybe it might have even
reminded her of her nephew it would have
been a futile and foolish idea for
yolanda to have even tried to remove the
drawing at any rate as any who try will
suffer that painful and horrifying
process of losing their organs and
having them appear in eric's paper lunch
bag even fire can't remove the drawing
from the fridge at least not permanently
suggesting that even the paper it is
drawn on has its own anomalous
properties on three separate occasions
the scp foundation has attempted to test
this setting
scp-683-2 on fire with nothing more than
a match every time the drawing was
incinerated burning to ashes until there
was nothing left but within 68 hours
scp-683-2 had returned to its permanent
fixture on the fridge door as if nothing
had happened interestingly though the
d-class members of personnel that were
instructed to burn the drawing didn't
suffer the usual anomalous effects of
scp-683
a similar thing happens if multiple
people attempt to remove
scp-683-2 or say anything negative
towards the drawing in cases like this
only the very first person who made a
disparaging remark or trying to rip the
drawing from the fridge will be the one
to suffer a long painful torture by
organ removal followed swiftly by death
now if you cast your mind back to
earlier in the video we told you that
someone who tries removing or disparages
scp-683-2 will only suffer an anomalous
lack of organs when they next eat
something so you must be thinking that
the way to avoid that is to simply not
eat too fast and not ingest a single
meal and yes you'd be right that does
stave off the anomalous effects of the
fridge and the drawing but also means
you're heading towards an even slower
painful death from starvation to date
two different foundation test subjects
have died this way by refusing to eat
after interacting with
scp-683 true the scp foundation is most
likely sitting on a whole cavocate of
different anomalies that can keep a
person alive without the need for food
but you know what they're like right the
foundation's hardly likely to share the
keys to surviving without having to eat
and there you have it folks that's
scp-683
don't worry it's highly unlikely that
you'll ever encounter it the foundation
keeps it under lock and key in a cell
fitted with a steel door and reinforced
hinges
scp-683 remains covered in a large cloth
to prevent any members of personnel from
looking at it when the fridge isn't
being used for research or experiments
but you have to wonder what if it's not
the only fridge with these anomalous
properties after all it's rare for a
manufacturer to make just a single
refrigerator of a certain model maybe
you'd better be wary next time you visit
someone with an older model of fridge in
their kitchen and
just to be safe if there is a drawing
pin to the front door leave it where it
is now go check out killing living
graffiti
scp-1155 predatory street art and living
drawing
scp-085 hand-drawn cassie for more art
that really jumps off the page